c'est encore un projet pilote miss tout
se déroule bien cette mini usine devrait
bientôt être remplacée par une plus
grande qui va permettre de recycler un
produit très polluant la batterie de
véhicule électrique au lithium ion
un jour on va acheter des autobus des
camions que des autos qu'on va voir
arriver ici puis les batteries vont
avoir le petit logo luttions tu risques
la gestion a mis au point une
technologie qui permet de démanteler les
batteries mécaniquement quelques minutes
alors que manuellement il faut une
quarantaine d'heures de travail puis de
récupérer 95 % des minéraux recyclables
à l'aide de procédés chimiques
du jamais vu ce qu'on fait c'est
vraiment l'économie circulaire
l'objectif c'est de retrouver les
composants pour refaire des nouvelles
batteries par la suite qu'on va être
capable d'aller chercher du carbonate de
lithium du nickel du cobalt pour vendre
ensuite aux fabricants de batteries et
qu'ils puissent faire des nouvelles
batteries plus verte
pour l'instant le marché est minuscule
faute de batterie russe khl et l'année
passée par exemple moi j'avais entendu
parler d'environ 3 batteries de
véhicules électriques à recycler cette
année on parle d'environ 400 mhz et dans
très peu de temps le même marché va
exploser dans nos resta merkin va
atteindre 300 milles batteries en fin de
vie en 2024 et ses 150 milles en 2030 et
au québec 21 mai les 88000 batterie
durant la même période
on recycle actuellement des batteries
ion dizaines de vies ces quelques
milliers de véhicules au québec
mais plus on avance plus le volume vont
être importants et à pleine maturité
si on est capable de recycler 80% des
batteries pour les réinjecter dans la
fabrication en fin de compte de
nouvelles batteries ça voudrait dire
qu'on a réussi de paris même si le
projet du zen démarre à peine avec
l'injection de près de 5 millions de
dollars du provincial recyclage litlle
on a déjà des projets d'expansion dans
ses cartons ce qu'on va faire c'est
réussi à développer au moins dix projets
en amérique du nord ce qui représente
25% du marché pour recycler les
batteries dans chacun des grandes villes
d'amérique du nord
même chose en europe recyclage ditions
prévoit ouvrir sa première usine à
montréal autour de 2023 il c'est normal
grondin radio canada montréal